president Trump's initial reaction to
the US Supreme Court decision today on
Twitter one word Wow
he had much more to say later chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
has that part of the story today's
Supreme Court ruling just coming out a
tremendous success a tremendous victory
for the American people and for our
Constitution in the Cabinet Room with
Republican members of Congress today
President Trump with praise for the
Supreme Court decision on his travel ban
we have to be tough and we have to be
safe and we have to be secure at a
minimum we have to make sure that we vet
people coming into the country we know
who's coming in we know where they're
coming from
the ranking member of the Senate
Judiciary Committee disagreed with the
president and the majority opinion and a
statement senator dick durbin saying
history will not be kind to this
president's policies or the Supreme
Court justices who lent their names to
this troubling ruling though the Supreme
sent the case back to the lower courts
for further proceedings
president Trump considers the matter
settled well I think it's pretty much a
final word at the Supreme Court you know
we went up the decision put some
much-needed wind in the president sails
he has been battered by public outcry
over the separation of families at the
border his aides hounded at restaurants
and their homes today he doubled down in
his calls for Congress to give him what
he wants to secure the southern border
we have to change it it's so simple it's
called I'm sorry you can't come in you
have to go in through a legal process
you don't have to see a judge where the
judge is going to take three years
before you can come back in the meantime
you never come
because you're already in the country
and she keeps up the pressure on illegal
immigration President Trump also took
aim today at an American icon a year ago
he was praising Harley Davidson for
building its bikes in the USA today he
ripped them for plans to shift some
production to Thailand the president
tweeting a harley-davidson should never
be built in another country never if
they move watch it will be the beginning
of the end they surrendered they quit
the aura will be gone and they will be
taxed like never before
Harley Davidson says it was the threat
of retaliation to the president's trade
tariffs that forced the move and that
only Harley's to be sold in Europe are
affected President Trump today insisted
it had nothing to do with tariffs they
announced it earlier this year so
harley-davidson is using that as an
excuse and I don't like that because
I've been very good to Harley Davidson
and they used it as an excuse and I
think the people that ride Harley's are
not happy with Harley Davidson and I
wouldn't be either Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan who shares a home state with
Harley Davidson says he's no fan of
tariffs
I don't think tariffs are the right way
to go I think tariffs are basically
taxes and what ends up happening is you
get escalating tariffs or escalating
taxes on immigration White House
officials tell me they expected the
measure that should be before the house
tomorrow likely won't go anywhere so the
next move would likely be a narrowly
tailored bill to supersede the 1997
court settlement that only allows
children to be held in detention with
the parents for a period of 20 days
officials say it's far less than what
the president has been asking for but a
lot better than what will happen if DHS
and the border patrol start separating
families again Brett John Roberts live
in the North Lawn John thank you